ok, je viens face au vent, dans quelle
direction va-t-il décoller euh de la
même manière qu'il pointe euh euh, il va
probablement décoller dans le sens ouais, comme
il va là-bas maintenant, imag, ok, je viens juste
à côté de lui
ouais, près de toi  je me sens à
l'aise ouais je veux juste attendre qu'il
parte de là euh Dan j'ai
du mal à t'entendre je ne suis pas
euh tu n'es pas assez près de ton micro
ou
quelque chose comme ça, c'est un peu mieux
ouais à peine  mais je, je peux y faire
face, vas-y, ok, je suis prêt à y aller, ok, vas-y
et euh, décolle, nous allons nous
approcher, euh tout près, quand tu sortiras, tu vas t'incliner
à droite ou
à gauche,
ok, tu es  je vais aller à gauche et
donc nous serons sur votre côté droit et nous voilà,
ok, nous devrions juste arrêter d'
enregistrer, nous
attendrons un côté
[Musique] rapide,
ok, je suppose que nous allons devoir
faire l'objectif  à un moment donné euh ouais donc c'était
juste un peu pénible mais je peux
le faire très
vite, découvrons d'abord où se trouve le terrain
ouais ok ok euh ouais si tu peux
rester sur lui je vais monter et partir
autour de lui, ok, peux-
tu faire une main gauche R faire une
main droite, ok euh Danny, je vais
monter et faire le tour de toi euh juste
au-dessus de
toi tu es prêt ouais 2 un ici nous
[Musique]
vas-y ouais
adorable ok arrête d'enregistrer car je ne
photographie que
ce petit avion est plutôt sympa en
jaune ouais ça correspond, c'est
beaucoup plus beau que les blancs ça correspond
au PO je veux dire l'herbe
ouais devrait pouvoir se rapprocher de
son  l'espace de ce
côté ouais Focus
truc ok de retour je ne peux pas voir désolé désolé ouais c'est
un angle de caméra parfait
depuis le
spray ils ont un bug [ __ ] ok
on va découvrir où est le champ et
ok D on'  Je vais devoir atterrir et
nettoyer un bug, donc si vous pouviez juste
orbiter pendant quelques
minutes, pas de
problème,
ok, arrêter
l'enregistrement, je ne voulais pas vous frapper, je
dois juste pouvoir voir où il est
désolé, je n'ai pas vu  l'avion était, je ne
passe pas devant lui, il pourrait devenir
vraiment moche très vite, tu vois toute cette
peinture jaune voler autour et Stu
les bruits bizarres, je déteste
ça autour et je filme ce Ste
ici même ouais ouais, ça a l'
air
sympa, prolonge ton vent arrière  juste un petit
peu ok allons-y,
tir
ok continue toujours à rouler ouais
ouais j'arrive maintenant c'est
[Musique]
il ok je vais à Dum essaye d'essayer de
le poursuivre
encore
ah ça a l'air vraiment sympa ouais tente notre
chance dans le
bus
Focus  ouais
ouais ok il va en arrière à gauche est-ce qu'il ouais il va il
va à
droite qu'est-ce qu'il va faire tu vas y aller
comme tu veux ok je vais y aller à
droite ok nous sommes derrière
toi
ok il va revenir en arrière et partir  en arrière
euh dans le sens inverse il est venu
ok je vais essayer de passer devant
toi cette fois euh euh Danny donc je coupe
devant toi
maintenant on va traverser devant eux
ouais même si on les met  notre liste si
tu voulais
ce que je vais faire très bien ok ça a
l'air
bien ok ok il est sorti il ​​est à notre gauche
maintenant c'est l'angle de caméra parfait pour le
support de caméra sur la
gauche excellent angle J l'as-tu eu ouais il a
l'air réel  doux parce que je ne peux pas le
voir ouais on dirait que tu pourrais le voir
sur le moniteur là-bas, je ne suis pas sûr ouais je
regarde par la fenêtre je vais juste
maintenir le réglage
ouais ok je le vois
maintenant,
pourquoi ne pas couper derrière moi  non, peut-être pas
couper derrière eux et tirer juste un peu
puis s'éloigner
[Musique]
ouais c'était sympa petit
mouvement, un coup de feu ouais ok
ok arrête l'enregistrement d'attendre que
nous nous alignions cette
fois
ok ok maintenant  ici, nous
[Musique]
allons nous enfuir et nous cacher
maintenant Je vais vous dire ce que je vais faire J'ai un
dos sur le Lan J'ai deux sacs Sur le LAN
ok arrête d'
enregistrer ok je m'en vais tu es 13h00  euh, je viens de
grimper au-dessus de toi, je t'ai compris,
ce que je vais faire, c'est traverser le
terrain, Danny et te faire entrer
en dessous de moi si tu peux, cela devrait être
un problème. Je vais me lever pour que nous soyons
au milieu du terrain.  quand tu traverses en dessous de
nous, ça sonne
bien,
arrête l'enregistrement à partir d'une
pause, ça a l'air vraiment
sympa,
il se lève un peu, laisse-le se rapprocher de
nous,
continue sur ça, ouais, ok, fais une
pause un instant, c'était
un
large SKS SKS là
[Musique]
ok, si tu commences à assouplir  maintenant
Jim
copie ouais continue de ralentir ici ça a
l'air
bien ok
gentil sympa ouais très
sympa ok on le fait on en fait un de plus
arrêter d'enregistrer d'
accord je suis déjà sur le
terrain presque devant nous mais ce n'est pas grave
continue de chier non  continue juste ouais
je vais essayer euh
ouais je vais juste essayer de prendre de la vitesse
ici je ne sais pas où il va bien 11
11h00
bas 11h00 tu veux que je bouge
ouais ouais SL SLE fini  vers la gauche un
peu ouais ça a l'air sympa ouais ça
vient bien je l'ai eu
à quelle distance es-tu en arrière tu
te casses à droite ne casse pas à
gauche bre pause à
gauche
ok je peux arrêter l'enregistrement s'il te plaît
je vais devoir tirer un peu
plus fort sur le  à l'autre bout ok il est juste
dans l'
ombre
ok regarde six heures
maintenant je vais y aller
ok
quel est le seul plan auquel je pense J nous
pourrions si nous sommes en bas
pareil peut-être si nous
mettons une copie ok je suis  je vais plonger,
nous serons vraiment au ras du
sol, tu l'as, je l'ai, je l'ai, ouais, je l'ai, ouais, c'est ouais,
tir latéral, ouais, ça a l'air
génial, il reste
cette
fois [Musique], ok, est-ce que tu viens de, euh, devrions-nous en faire
un de plus ?  ceux dans l'autre sens à
notre arrangement de 9h00 à 15h00 arrêtent la promotion de l'enregistrement
ok
attends qu'il nous rattrape il va nous
rattraper ok là il
est
pareil l'a eu
maintenant
ok
arrête
hé on va à leur droite  faites-les
non de l'autre côté Jim, je pense qu'il a dit que
j'avais la caméra pointée vers 9h00 et
que si nous pouvions
le dépasser, il glisserait sur le côté droit
là-bas, cet avion viendrait de
la
droite arrive à
15h00
ouais il est
là,
il roule toujours ouais il roule toujours
ouais ouais ok je vais le revoir ok
bien sûr que ce sera sympa de venir chez
toi ok c'est
vrai que ça marche ouais ouais un peu
aussi  fermer peut-être revenir dessus euh un
peu plus haut
ok jusqu'à là où je
peux ok tu es prêt ouais 3 2
[Musique]
1 ok gentil merci ok arrête ça
arrêter doit être de retour là où il
est là vas-y euh c'est la bonne base
d'après la copie
qu'il est sur une bonne base pour
atterrir, vous avez probablement Bo ici hors de cette
eau maintenant où vous voulez être euh vous le
voulez à 15h00 oui s'il vous plaît ouais nous
pouvons faire
ça en
utilisant toute sa bande n'est-ce pas
L'
atterrissage parfait, ok, ok, allons nous garer, ok,
cool.